[Music]
i want to talk about a really fun collab
friends don't let friends oh god calm is
red power leave here serious rocker
how'd that all come about well i wrote
it with thomas rhett we were down at the
beach and we were we were watching our
kids kind of playing around and and we
both had a beard in our hands and he
goes man i've been wanting to write a
song called friends don't let friends
drink alone and
and we were just sitting there and we
wrote the chorus
right there while we were just sitting
around having a beer
you know that's right i will leave you
by yourself jack no sir i played it for
darius rucker on the golf course i said
check out this song at thomas
he was like i want to sing on it who can
handle their drinks the best darius
harley or thomas
oh
between the three and maybe derek gets
darris gets the most wild yeah and then
the second one thomas red and then carly
she drinks wine
yes dear harris is all about whiskey and
thomas rhett's all about his tequila yes
friends don't let friends is just one of
the incredible tracks off of lady a's
eight studio album
but that's not the only thing the trio
is celebrating
our wedding anniversary is this january
i'm on january 7th and then dave and his
wife kelly are april 14th so we've got
decade long marriages that's so exciting
are you guys good gift givers put a song
for his wife kelly on this record that
was her mother's day gifts so he also
gifts things that
are one of a kind literally lady ace
kids share a special bond as well
would you support their choice if they
wanted to get into the music industry
yeah yeah sure absolutely maybe he has a
band together yeah a super group of six
kids together
[Music]